pero mientras 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniel hablando daniela buena
noche bienvenida las bolsas recibieron
con beneplácito a job agent
hola raúl muy buenas noches mire hubo
triple récord en la bolsa de nueva york
y según los expertos esta fue la mejor
jornada en una toma de posesión
estadounidense en los últimos 36 años
los principales índices de wall street
el dow jones de industriales- el
standard and poor's y el tecnológico
nasdaq registraron máximos históricos
este último animado también por la
disparada en bolsa de netflix de más del
17 por ciento luego de mostrar muy
buenos resultados financieros los
mercados de otras partes del mundo
también tuvieron ganancias en europa por
ejemplo cerraron al alza
fráncfort parís y londres además de
madrid a las que no se dejaron contagiar
tanto de la euforia fueron las bolsas
latinoamericanas que se tiñeron de rojo
casi todo el mundo tiene el ojo puesto
raúl en las medidas económicas que
comenzará a impulsar job haití
y zinc creo que los inversionistas se
centrarán ante todo en el paquete de
estímulo del que ya se ha estado
empezando a hablar
no solo en su aprobación sino en cómo
será el proceso qué tipo de apoyo se va
a recibir
banier a un tema muy importante y es
como la llegada del valle de impactará a
los bolsillos de las personas
mire el nuevo presidente de eeuu tiene
una misión muy difícil recuperar la
malherida economía como ya se sabe lo
primero que anunció fue un nutrido
paquete de estímulos económicos de 1,9
billones de dólares o de millones de
millones si lo aprueba el congreso
implicaría un cheque de 1.400 dólares
por familia entre otros alivios también
por ejemplo a las empresas pero también
hay otros temas clave como por ejemplo
que joe biden propone un aumento del
salario mínimo para que sea de 15
dólares por hora también quiere que
suban los impuestos de renta de las
empresas al 28 por ciento así como de
las personas que ganen más de 400 mil
dólares por año otra de sus propuestas
tiene que ver con las pensiones
los demócratas han venido presionando
para que los empleadores faciliten el
ahorro de jubilación de millones de
trabajadores de menos ingresos y para
que también tengan los mismos beneficios
fiscales de los que ganan más así señala
pero es que este año también se espera
la recuperación de gran parte de los
empleos turísticos perdidos por causa de
la pandemia si el consejo mundial de
viajes y turismo cree que el camino
hacia la recuperación del sector que es
probablemente el más afectado por la
pandemia empezará en marzo esto porque
porque muchas de las principales de
empresas ya están registrando
incrementos en las reservas para el
verano en 2020 se estima que se
perdieron en total 140 millones de
puestos de trabajo del sector turístico
en el mejor de los escenarios este año
se recuperarían 111 millones y en el
escenario más pesimista se espera
vincular de nuevo a 84 millones de
personas de todas maneras estos niveles
siguen siendo muy bajos con respecto a
2019 y cambiamos ahora información
porque hay furor en el mundo bursátil
por la reaparición pública de uno de los
hombres más ricos de china pero puede
que a usted le suene este nombre jack ma
él es el hombre de negocios más famosos
de china
y fundador de alibaba que junto con
amazon son los reyes del comercio
electrónico mundial pues este excéntrico
y muy carismático jack ma llevaba 88
días sin aparecer públicamente
exactamente desde octubre de 2020 en
medio de una disputa que tuvo con el
gobierno chino que le abría una
investigación por supuestas prácticas de
monopolio después de esos roces algunos
medios decían que estaba detenido otros
que simplemente mantenía silencio y hay
quienes incluso lo dieron por
desaparecido lo cierto es que abundaron
las especulaciones sobre su paradero
pues al finalmente apareció de nuevo en
un corto vídeo publicado por la prensa
local lo más llamativo raúl es que desde
pequeños saludo disparó las acciones de
alí babá nueva york en casi 6 % y eso en
plata blanca son más de 36 mil millones
de dólares ya quisiera 1 radio a
aparecer de manera así es tenía la
comisión por él no estaba muerto estaba
de parranda señor tiene la cifra del
diario 7,8 millones de euros o fue la
multa impuesta por bruselas a la
plataforma de videojuegos estadounidense
una de las más reconocidas del mundo y 5
desarrolladoras europeas lo hizo porque
estas empresas impidieron que los
usuarios comprarán copias del juego más
baratas en otros países del bloque
comunitario así deja niell a gracias por
toda la información entonces es buena
noche y ustedes también continúen con
nosotros